[Música]
Pues seguimos en directo a América
edición nocturna con la economía para
ello tenemos ya listo nuestro estudio a
Juan Pablo locumi Juan Pablo bienvenido
a este estudio vamos a hablar hoy de
Estados Unidos y las tensiones políticas
por el techo de la deuda en el país
empecemos hablando de qué es exactamente
el techo de la deuda Así es Rodrigo Pues
el techo límite de la deuda es un tope
legal que se pone sobre la cantidad
total de dinero que el Gobierno Federal
está autorizado a pedir prestado a
través de valores del tesoro de Estados
Unidos como bonos de capitalización esto
para cumplir con sus obligaciones
financieras la primera Economía del
mundo tampoco se salva de los déficits
presupuestarios y por esta razón debe
pedir prestado enormes sumas de dinero
para pagar sus cuentas vamos a ver
entonces los principales datos de este
tema y es que este año el techo era de
31,4 billones de dólares de hecho que se
superó el 19 de enero también hay otros
países que tienen esta particularidad
pero son casos muy especiales como el
caso Colonia en el cual la deuda o más
bien el presupuesto es tan amplio que
nunca llegan a este límite y en el caso
de Dinamarca en donde solamente la deuda
pública puede sobrepasar el 60% del pib
vemos entonces que el límite se ha
aumentado 78 veces desde 1960 esto en
Estados Unidos lo que quiere decir que
pues esta vez puede que también suceda
lo mismo y vemos el caso de Barack Obama
2011 en donde Aunque al final Pues sí se
aumentó este límite llegó hasta lo
último y eso generó incertidumbre en los
mercados financieros estos son los datos
principales entonces a tener en cuenta
pero nosotros hablamos con Alberto
Bernal director de estrategia global de
XP investment desde Nueva York Estados
Unidos y él los explicó en términos
cotidianos la estructura del
endeudamiento estadounidense
básicamente Qué es básicamente es que el
hay un límite hay un número específico
del tamaño de la deuda pública que la
legislación permite pues por ejemplo
para poner un cambio un ejemplo casero
supongamos que una familia se pone un
límite de que solamente puede tener 60
mil dólares de deuda en algún momento
dado Entonces ese límite serían 60.000 y
después de 60.000 no se puede seguir
endeudando en el caso de Estados Unidos
es igual pero porque es muy particular
en el caso del sistema fiscal de Estados
Unidos Entonces se tiene cuando se
llegan a los límites de la deuda tiene
que haber una acción legislativa o sea
el congreso de la República tiene que
aprobar el número a un número dado por
ejemplo en el caso poniendo que fuese
60.000 a 70 mil dólares pues Tendría que
haber una resolución de la familia en
este caso una resolución del Congreso de
la república para permitir que Estados
Unidos pueda seguir incre ese tamaño de
la deuda Por qué Se incrementa el tamaño
de la deuda Pues porque obviamente
Estados Unidos al igual que muchos otros
países en el mundo tiene un problema de
déficit fiscal bueno Juan Pablo hablemos
ahora de los momentos clave de este
techo de la deuda de este tema porque
normalmente se suele alargar por varios
meses Así es vamos a ver las fechas
principales de este tema porque todo
empezó el 19 de enero Cuando entonces
Estados Unidos alcanzó el techo de la
deuda desde este día al tesoro empezó a
activar entonces las medidas
extraordinarias pero no fue Sino hasta
el 25 de enero que pues ahí como que
hizo el anuncio la secretaria del tesoro
medidas que entre otras es suspender los
pagos de los fondos de pensiones de
trabajadores públicos y suspender los
pagos al servicio de salud el primero de
febrero una reunión entre biden y el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy que entre
todo dijeron vamos bien Pero vamos a
seguir hablando de este tema para ver a
dónde llegamos luego el 7 de febrero
biden empezó a decir los republicanos
como re en la economía de Estados Unidos
esto lo hizo en el discurso de la unión
atacó directamente a los republicanos y
más adelante dijo que los republicanos
estaban jugando con la política es algo
que ha estado haciendo todo el tiempo
para hablar sobre este tema que es muy
importante para Estados Unidos
finalmente la fecha límite para tomar
una decisión será junio en donde el
tesoro ha dicho que podrían agotarse los
recursos que han activado hasta el
momento y que pues no va a haber más
tiempo para poder hablar de este tema
una noticia que están en desarrollo como
lo podemos ver pero hoy hablamos de este
tema porque el solo hecho de Elevar el
límite de deuda que se hace tantas veces
se ha convertido en un verdadero
conflicto político porque muchas veces
la oposición del gobierno lo usa como
estrategia para imponer reducciones
presupuestarias a la administración de
turno Y así sentir que tiene un poco de
control sobre algunas decisiones
económicas de la casa blanca y en este
caso los republicanos dicen que no
bloquearían este aumento del techo
siempre y cuando vayan se comprometa a
recortar el gasto público esto nos dijo
el invitado lo que pasa es que
republicanos pues obviamente no tienen
la Casa Blanca entonces quieren
mostrarse agresivos en términos del
gasto público del déficit para mendar
para mandar un mensaje de que el partido
demócrata y la Casa Blanca bajo yo
baiden no ha tenido la capacidad de
disminuir suficientemente el déficit el
déficit fiscal entonces lo que quieren
los los republicanos es decir está bien
yo incremento el techo de la deuda para
que Estados Unidos no entren un
incumplimiento de sus obligaciones Con
la condición de que ustedes partido
demócrata partido de gobierno
demuestren ser responsables y en ese
sentido demuestren tener la capacidad de
disminuir el gasto público y los
demócratas dicen no no queremos
disminuir el gasto público porque eso va
a afectar a la gente y lo que queremos
es que los ricos paguen más en las
empresas paguen más Y de esa forma
incrementar el las fuentes de recaudo y
no necesaria incrementar el gasto bueno
normalmente este tema se suele
solucionar antes de un escenario de
impago pero que sucedería en Estados
Unidos si finalmente se diera sin pago
Rodrigo pues es muy difícil que esto
pase algunos analistas le han dado solo
un 1% de probabilidad de que esto suceda
Porque además sería catastrófico vemos
que Estados Unidos es la que da la línea
económica al resto del mundo pero
precisamente hablando de este tema
nuestro invitado nos dio más detalles de
lo que tal vez podría pasar en este caso
que Estados Unidos llegase a tener un
impago en su deuda pública sería por
mucho por mucho el evento financiero más
catastrófico de la historia moderna
porque Estados Unidos es la base de la
pirámide es la base de la estructura los
bonos de Estados Unidos son los bonos
que mayor seguridad le dan a los
inversionistas Entonces si Estados
Unidos deja de pagar su deuda
Entonces los inversionistas van a decir
a ver si Estados Unidos me incumple ese
pago de deuda pues qué podría yo Pensar
de un Bono de Brasil de un Bono de Perú
de un Bono de Colombia un Bono de
Inglaterra etcétera Pero yo insisto en
que este escenario necesariamente tiene
que ser un escenario de poca
probabilidad porque es tan grave es tan
grave esta situación que pues generaría
unos unos movimientos ridículos pues
Juan Pablo Muchas gracias por este
repaso de un tema que seguramente dará
todavía mucho que hablar